نتحول الان مشاهدينا الى خبر عاجل ورد
الينا منذ قليل حيث افادت وسائل اعلام
عراقيه بان 40 صاروخا اطلقت على قاعده عين
الاسد التي تضم قوات امريكيه في محافظه
الانبار العراقيه واكد مصدر امني في الحشد
العشائري بمحافظه الانبار غرب بغداد
استهداف قاعده عين الاسد بصواريخ انطلقت
من منطقه البغدادي القريبه من قاع عين
الاسد واضاف المصدر ان قوات التحالف
الدولي ردت بقصف المنطقه التي اطلقت منها
الصواريخ بنحو 18 صاروخا دون معرفه حجم
الخسائر بين
الجانبين هذا ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول
امريكي قوله ان عددا من الامريكيين اصيب
بجراح جراء القصف الذي استهدف قاعده عين
الاسد كما نقلت رويترز عن مص مصدر امني
عراقي اصابه عدد من قوات الامن العراقيين
بجروح خطيره في الهجوم وقال مسؤول امريكي
ان التقييم الاضافي لا يوضح ما اذا كانت
القاعده قد قصفت بصواريخ ام قذائف وبانه
يجري تقيييم
الوضع ينضم الينا من بغداد مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي ومن واشنطن مراسل للجزيره عبد
الفتاح فايد ونبدا معك عامر لافي
والمعلومات المتوفره حتى اللحظه اييه في
بغداد ومن الجانب العراقي عن هذا الهجوم
على قاعده عين
الاسد نعم حسن طبعا هذا الهجوم هو ياتي في
اطار مسلسل الاستهداف المستمر من قبل
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه لقواعد التحالف
الدولي سواء في العراق هنا او في في سوريا
وا وفقا للتصريحات الامريكيه او اخر تصريح
امريكي في هذا الاطار تجاوز عدد هذه
الاستهدافات
130 استهدافا للقواعد كما ذكرنا سواء في
العراق او في سوريا بالنسبه لهذا
الاستهداف اليوم والذي يميزه حسن هو انه
يوصف بانه يعني استهداف باكبر رشقه
صاروخيه منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه اي من ذو
السابع من اكتوبر الحديث عن استهداف قاعده
عين الاسد باكثر من 40 صاروخا لكن هنا
مصادر في الفصائل فصائل المقاومه العراقيه
تنفي ان تكون هذه الصواريخ بالستيه كما
كان الحديث في بدايه الاعلان عن هذه الرشق
الصاروخيه وتقول بان الصواريخ التي
استخدمت هي صواريخ من نوع جراد نعم حشد
العشائري في الانبار تحدث عن ان الاستهداف
وقع من منطقه البغدادي القريبه من القاعده
قاعده الاسد عين الاسد و ايضا الحديث ايضا
مؤكد عن ان القوات الامريكيه وقوات
التحالف الدولي في هذه القاعده استهدفت
ايضا مصادر اطلاق النيران لكن الى الان لا
يوجد معلومات عن تاثير وتداعيات هذا
الاستهداف والرد من جانب القوات الامريكيه
النقطه الاخرى والمهمه ايضا حسن الحديث عن
الاصابات داخل هذه القاعده نقلت وكالات
انباء عالميه عن ان هناك جنود عراقيين
اصيبوا في داخل هذه القاعده لا يوجد اي
تصريح رسمي عراقي بهذا الخصوص لكن ايضا
مصادر في الفصائل فصائل المقاومه العراقيه
تحدثت عن انه لا يوجد ابدا اي اصابه في
صفوف القوات العراقيه وانما الاصابات فقط
في صفوف قوات التحالف الدولي وعلى راسها
طبعا تعلم الولايات المتحده وانه لا يوجد
اصابات في داخل قوات العراقيه نوضح طبعا
للساده المشاهدين بان هذه القاعده هي
مقسومه الى قسمين قسم للتحالف الدولي الذي
تزعمه الولايات المتحده وقسم للقوات
العراقيه منفصل نوعا ما وبالتالي الفصائل
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه تتحدث عن استهداف
القسم الذي يوجد فيه فص يوجد فيه القوات
الامريكيه وقوات التحالف النقطه المهمه
ايضا ربما بهذا واختم بها حسن التصريح
والبيان الذي صدر عن ممثليه الامم المتحده
هنا في بغداد والتي قالت بان العراق ينجر
شيئا فشيئا الى الصراعات المستمره في
الشرق الاوسط وبان استمرار هذه الهجمات هو
يقود الاستقرار الذي حدث ونجحت العراق في
تحقيقه بجهد جهيد هذا التصريح اساء استياء
كبير في الاوساط هنا في تقريبا المنصات
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي واعتبر واعتبره
كثير من العراقيين بمثابه تهديد للعراقيين
على اعتبار انه اوقفوا الهجمات على
الامريكان والا فان استقرار العراق سيكون
مهددا هذا الموقف او هذا البيان صدر
منمن من الامم المتحده من ممثليه الامم
المتحده هنا في العراق طيب عامر ايضا
استهداف هذه القاعده باكبر رشقه صاروخيه
حتى الان هل سبقه اي حدث امني او تحرك
ميداني لافت هل حصل شيء قبل هذه الرشق
الصاروخيه الامريكيه اصبح حدثا شبه يومي
هنا في العراق وفي سوريا كما ذكرنا ولكن
المنفذ الصوت يتقطع معك عامر لافي سنعود
اليك طبعا ل لمزيد من المعلومات عن كيفيه
حصول هذا الهجوم بالصواريخ على قاعده عين
الاسد الامريكيه في العراق عبد الفتاح
فايد ماذا يقول الجانب الامريكي و و ما هي
المعلومات
بشان هذا الهجوم المتداوله في
واشنطن نعم حسن في الحقيقه تواصلنا مع
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون وايضا
مع القياده الوسطى الامريكيه واكد بان
انهما على علم بالتقارير حول هجوم على
قاعده عين الاسد وانهما يتابعان هذا الامر
دون اعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل لكن
التفاصيل التي ترد ترد في وسائل الى
الاعلام التي تنقل عن مسؤوليين امريكيين
وتؤكد ب استهداف قاعده عين الاسد
الامريكيه في العراق غرب العراق برشقه
صاروخيه كبيره وبان هناك مصابين من الجانب
الامريكي دون الحديث عن عدد المصابين هناك
تقارير تتحدث عن اصابه جنديين دون ايضا
تفاصيل حول حجم تلك الاصابه لكن هناك
تقارير اعلاميه كثيره حسن تتحدث بالفعل
كما اشار الزميل عامر لافي من بغداد بان
ان هذه هي اكبر ضربه من نوعها تستهدف
قاعده عين الاسد منذ بدء الهجوم على غزه
في السابع من اكتوبر وان اكثر ضمن اكثر من
100 استهداف تعرضت له تلك القاعده تحديدا
والتي تمثل على ما يبدو بالنسبه
للعراقيين رمزيه كبيره للوجود الامريكي في
العراق والذي تقول تلك الجماعات المسلحه
التي تستهدف قاعده عين الاسد وغيرها من
القواعد الامريكيه في المنطقه بانها ستظل
هدفا لها طالما بقي الاحتلال الامريكي
للعراق وطالما بقيت هذه الحرب في غزه
وبالتالي هناك من جانب هذه الجماعات
المسلحه جماعات المقاومه العراقيه هناك
مبرر احدهما داخلي محلي يتعلق بما
يعتبرونه احتلالا امريكيا للعراق والاخر
هو هذا الاستهداف وهذه الحرب حرب التي
يصفون بحرب اباده وتطهير عرقي في غزه حتى
تتوقف هذه الحرب سيظل هذا الاستهداف
موجودا وقائما طبعا حسن هذا ليس الاستهداف
الاول وهذه ليست القاعده الوحيده التي
تتعرض للاستهداف فقبل يومين فقط قوات
امنيه عراقيه اسقطت مسيره مفخخه كانت
تستهدف قاعده امريكيه قرب مطار اربيل في
كردستان العراق في شمال العراق وبالتالي
هذه الهجمات هي مستمره كما كانت هناك
هجمات ايضا على قاعده امريكيه في سوريا
وبالتالي هذه تقول جماعات المقاومه
العراقيه بانها ستظل ستظل تمارس دورها في
مقاومه الاحتلال الامريكي للاراضي
العراقيه كما تقول وايضا لتخفيف الضغط على
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه ح ابقى معنا عبد
الفتاح فايد اعود اليك عامر لافي عندما
سالتك ان كانت هناك ايه احداث سبقت اشرت
الى ان استهداف هذه القاعده والقواعد
الامريكيه الاخرى بات عملا يوميا او شبه
يومي منذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
ولكن هل هناك في العراق اليوم من يربط او
حاول ان يربط بين هذا الاستهداف الاكبر من
نوعه لقاعده عين الاسد
وعمليه الاغتيال التي حصلت في سوريا لقاده
من الحرس الثوري
الايراني نعم حسن لا يوجد الى الان اي جهه
حاولت ان تربط بين الهجومين الحديث هنا
ثابت في هذا الاطار وهو انه ودعما
للمقاومه في غزه و ورفضا للهجمات
الاسرائيليه والحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
نقوم بتوجيه هذه الضربات على الجهه التي
تدعم اسرائيل في هذه الحرب والمقصود هنا
طبعا الولايات المتحده وقوات التحالف
الدوليه وهذا هو ما يصدر دائما عن فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه ذكر سالتني ربما قبل
انق قطاع الصوت عن ما الذي ما الجديد او
ما الذي حدث بشيء مختلف ربما قبل استهداف
هذه القاعده بهذا العدد الكبير من
الصواريخ ربما يعني هناك من يحاول ان
يتحدث عن ما اعلنت عنه فصائل المقاومه
العراقيه قبل يومين من اسقاطها لمسيره
تجسس امريكيه في سماء محافظه دياله
والحديث هنا ونوعيه الربط عن ان هذه
المسيره كانت تبحث عن اهداف لها لتضرب
المقاومه العراقيه وبالتالي كانت هذه
الضربه الكبيره نوع من العمليات
الاستباقيه لاي استهداف من قبل الولايات
المتحده وقوات التحالف الدوليه ل اماكن
ربما الفصائل المقاومه العراقيه لكن كما
ذكرت قبل قليل لا يوجد حتى الان من حاول
ربط ما يجري في سوريا واستهداف المستشارين
العسكريين الايرانيين بهذه العمليه على
اعتبار ان ما تقوم به فصائل المقاومه
العراقيه هدفها الرئيس رئيسي فقط هو نصره
غزه ودعم صمود ودعم المقاومه في غزه فقط
ولا غير طيب عبد الفتاح فايد ربما في هذه
المره الحديث عن اصابات بين الجنود
الامريكيين في هذه
القاعده يدفع بالولايات المتحده الى
التعامل بشكل مختلف مع هذه الهجمات
الصاروخيه هل ثمه ما يؤشر الى ذلك في
الولايات المتحده
الان
بالفعل حسن يعني هناك تعامل مختلف كما
نشاهد في ردات الفعل الامريكيه على جماعات
المقاومه في المنطقه سواء في البحر الاحمر
في التعامل مع الحوثيين وايضا في جماعات
المقاومه في العراق
وهذه التحذيرات الامريكيه المستمره بعدم
توسيع نطاق الحرب وتقول انها لا تستهدف
الدخول في صراع مباشر مع تلك الجماعات
سواء في اليمن او في العراق او في لبنان
تؤكد اكثر من مره وعلى لسان اكثر من مسؤول
انها لا تستهدف الدخول في صراع مباشر مع
هذه الجماعات ولكنها ايضا تبعث برسا
برسائل الى ايران وقال ذلك الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لكي تلجم هذه الجماعات
كما تقول باعتبار ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
يقولون باستمرار بان تلك الجماعات هي
مدعومه من ايران وان ايران هي من تدربها
وتزودها بالسلاح وتحركها لكن ايضا في نفس
الوقت هي تقول انها لن تسكت ولن تصمت على
استهداف جنودها وقواعدها في المنطقه طبعا
هذا الاستهداف الكبير اليوم لا شك انه
يحمل رسائل كثيره ايضا الى الاداره
الامريكيه لانه اكبر استهداف من نوعه رشقه
صاروخيه تقدر وفقا لوسائل الاعلام باكثر
من 30 صاروخا وبالتالي هي الاكبر من نوعها
هي تاتي ايضا حسن بعد ايام من مقتل احد
قيادات الحشد الشعبي في العراق ابو تق في
الرابع من يناير الجاري الى جانب ما جرى
في استهداف لدمشق لقاده من الحرس الثوري
الايراني في دمشق اليوم وبالتالي هي ضربات
وضربات مضاده من الجانبين على ما يبدو لكن
اخيرا حسن المسؤولون الامريكيون كانوا قد
اكدوا بان خلال زياره لرئيس الوزراء
العراقي ولقاء مع رئيس الوزراء العراقي
بان الحكومه العراقيه لم تطلب رسميا اخراج
القوات الامريكيه وعلى ما يبدو كان ذلك
ردا على حجج المقاومه العراقيه وما تردده
جماعات المقاومه العراقيه من انها تقاوم
احتلالا وبالتالي هذه مقاومه شروعه
للاحتلال الى جانب بالتاكيد مساندتها
للفلسطينين في قطاع غزه في مواجهه حرب
الاباده والتطهير العرقي عبد الفتاح فايد
من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لعامر لافي
كان معنا من بغداد